rear view mirror rear view mirror rear
view mirror don't need to look behind me
don't need to look behind me
don't need to look behind me
don't
malignant [ __ ]
[Music]
what is up people after a very very long
day we are shooting this super late at
night on a saturday but it's jimmy juan
man malignant it's been getting uh
interesting mixed reviews here it's got
pretty solid critic score pretty low
audience score so it sounds like it's
going to be our kind of movie
that's just the vibe i'm getting if you
end up enjoying our reaction hit the
like button or the dislike button i
don't really care which one as long as
you hit one depending on your feelings
a-okay with that full-length watch as
long as we sync up with the time code
for malignant or over at our patreon
page and over there we cover a whole
bunch of shows we're at the same tier
you get the option for both reaction
highlights and watch along included and
thank you to pratham jindal for editing
now these highlights let's do it people
[Music]
dr weaver he got out again i tried this
to do it with ect but the leprechaun had
no effect on him then all the machines
started going crazy it was like he was
drinking the electricity and controlling
our machines
oh
boy
you've been a bad bad boy gabriel
what
oh my god
he speaks
he's broadcasting his thoughts
i swear that guy's a nurse on a csi show
it's time we cut out the cancer
[Music]
interesting
what do you mean a hard time just a
little more agitated than usual
do you have any tylenol
they say i can't take aspirin
if you've got all this pain maybe you
shouldn't be going to work i'll be fine
i promise
hey i was watching that you're barely
watching it
maybe you need to stop getting pregnant
please i just really need to lie down
you know the doctor said this could
happen again right how many times i have
to watch my children die inside of you
what the [ __ ] is this
is this a dream
are you saying this is my phone are you
saying this keeps happening
sorry
i'm gonna get you some ice okay okay i'm
gonna get you some ice hold on and
tylenol too not aspirin
oh you do not want to be
having the baby of that guy
oh god
this is a fun horror movie
just like insidious
oh there's like a shadow over him from a
human shadow for a second
i think
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no oh god
oh she's still bleeding jesus christ
my god go to the hospital
oh gross
gross
oh what the [ __ ]
[Music]
those crunchy contours
the amount of a head trauma this woman
is going through is absurd recite your
name your birth date your address
oh man don't go to sleep
morning rush
i really love the colors in this movie
so far yeah
holy [ __ ]
he's still alive
i don't believe this
why does james want to hate this woman
[Laughter]
we're gonna find out
the doctor said your sister had three
miscarriages in the last two years i
don't know why she wouldn't have told me
if there's anything
just give me a call yeah thank you
everyone on twitter is right this
movie's full of so much camp
[Music]
so silly so far jeez james won
mr mitchell used to knock mrs mitchell
around he beat her no forced injury
an abusive husband
motive
yeah
and means for her to gain the strength
to do something like that yes
got a strawberry gotta leave the bone
sticking out
yay
double door
[Laughter]
it took me a second
oh wow cool
wow
wow a cool shot
where are the wipes or what is this
house
you just feel this movie's gonna get
like [ __ ] bonkers
like oh crap it's already going like
this
yeah it's like there was like a monster
baby in the prologue
[Laughter]
that's a great shot
did the shadow kill her in her form from
the head trauma there
symbolism about leaving him by the time
i got the courage i got pregnant
i wanted to know what it felt like to to
have a blood connection with someone a
biological connection
mom and dad took me in when i was eight
i don't remember anything before that
mom told me that my biological mother
died during my birth cindy i'm adopted
hell yeah
i've never seen this from the opposite
angle
what a specific type of script yeah
the dot the dialogue to match this tone
it's really really interesting
you can't be down here why don't you go
plug those lights back in
whoa
whoa
what
i'm sorry who is this hello
[Music]
[Laughter]
excellence in surgery
there's no place we cannot fit an
ominous zoom
whoa
what are you doing at my house
this is my house
who are you
oh no
oh no
who are you
[Music]
whoa
jeez
wow
damn god
weird little perspective jiggles and
everything too so james juan described
it all my perspective jiggles
that's part of my signature
[Laughter]
it's like all of james juan with a
gelato vibe to it i just said gelato
[Laughter]
milk and eggs [ __ ]
really does
self-awareness in this movie
see
i'm on to you one
[Music]
cool it's like sleep paralysis but worse
wow
what is her connection to this thing is
it like an evil tumor that cut out of
her that is still connected to her or
something
what exactly did you see i killed again
this time across from the silver cup
apartments in north beacon hill i
googled that great
wikipedia brown hair just solved the
case
madison saw dr weaver die as it happened
subtle mr sunday shout out
if she's wrong you can have her
committed and you can put the cuffs on
me
is there a thing happening with them or
something
i cannot tell
what about your guns door's
[Laughter]
open oh
so i'm putting out a bolo on sloth from
the goonies
did we [ __ ] beat her she's
yeah like
i know you didn't know your suspect of
purpose still
so that was 93 when the tumor was cut
out right yeah that's maybe he has to be
trying to figure out whatever the hell
the twist is
[Laughter]
titles malignant it's got to mean
something
but you'll always be emily
you let them tell you i wasn't real like
i was just a voice and you believe them
i am going to make them pay for what
they did
one
by
one
cool yeah it's good reveal
oh hell
she was the doctor's patient
it was such a cheesy dialogue i love it
during the adoption did they say if i
had a brother or anything the only thing
they would say is if they were siblings
they tried to place them in the same
family and who the hell is gabriel
shut your mouth little girl why don't
you say that name
[Laughter]
i'm saying that
they are
are you talking to
gabriel
[Music]
is he your imaginary friend your girl
isn't made up says that you are he says
you're not my real family
my little christmas cuties right here
daddy play time's over
and we'll come down the chimney 94. yeah
okay
mommy said she'd love me when the baby
comes she's had
go-to
horror girl
so gabriel was something that i made up
whatever you went through before you
joined our family it hurt you in a way
that i can't even imagine i always
figured you created gabriel so that you
could survive that
we thought if we gave you enough love
we wouldn't need him anymore yeah
try telling that to gabriel i hope we
weren't wrong
that you're way wrong playing dead
bodies now today marks the seventh year
since emily may was entrusted into our
care emily started committing signs of
mental psychosis she says she's seeing
visions and hearing thoughts
from the devil
i've contacted dr john gregory asked
hopkins as well as dr victor fields from
florence weaver to victor fields working
the same case along with dr chuck
gregory
holy [ __ ] john gregory wow that's our
days what did we do it should be gregory
john i'm just holy [ __ ] i'm sorry man
that's okay john i'll call jimmy one
after this
i'm changing it
could do that on hbo oh
no
time for another murder yeah
in the shower
[Music]
maybe it is maybe right maybe it is like
something carved out of her but uh
even that's too predictable
gotta be something more weird something
crazier
[Music]
oh no oh no
oh no
he's still here
come on
[Music]
whoa
yeah missing search
i'm gonna try this
don't follow him
call for backup get your partner at
least she could take care of this
yeah you smart you smart stop going
stop i don't want you to just let him go
how what is the anatomy of this guy i
know he's like backwards and forwards
and
everything
oh just call it quits man
you already you're you're confirming top
of the year you know what it looks like
now
you know she's telling the truth
i need to commandeer this video
seattle pd
[Laughter]
if he just like got in there gabriel
just went in there
[Music]
so gabriel does parkour
oh [ __ ] me
i'm gonna go now just to let myself out
don't follow me
we are gonna turn back the hands of time
the bygone years reconstructing
themselves
i want you to go back to before the
adoption
yeah sure put everyone in the room
but he's here too
[Music]
okay
i'm the only one that can see him
she's sleeping
i guess
really you mean like a good surprise
[Music]
god what an effect
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a mislead
the killer said he was gabriel
are you saying that the killer is your
imaginary friend
yeah that's where we're at it's pretty
much him
we've been out for a while right yep is
there something that i'm missing
english please
but it's not it's real i mean gabriel
seems like a pretty real guy yeah from
everything that's happened
do we know who she is yet
not aside from just
she's just horse scenario yeah
but she must be connected
oh
maybe she's the real mom
maybe
she still looks pretty young
somebody else from the institute
whoa
whoa
what a reveal
[Laughter]
wait that was in her actual house it
wasn't like
just like she made a connection or
something right it seemed like it was
yeah because she wasn't there killing
her yeah
she just up and escaped
no
it's not
stop lying to us i'm sorry
and this is her first ever voicemail
who are you gabriel
i thought she had already told you
i'm a figment of her imagination
[Laughter]
ask her what she used to call me
the devil
maybe she's a psychic
and she's projecting these things
so it's just been sitting there empty
sorry i don't know that was before my
time
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] hang up on you
meanwhile in resident evil
it got that dark by the time you got
there it's a really long windy ride
[Laughter]
looks close
it fools you
it's like so dark
not worth it i'd wait till the day i
would bring literally anyone with me
oh god
just walk right into [ __ ] castlevania
god at least bring a camera and upload
some of this
are you sure you want to do this serena
mama won't help me she called my
pregnancy a transgression against god i
don't know how to look after them on my
own
he's an abomination
it's her child i guess
please look after emily
don't worry you can have peace no way
that's her that's him yeah
mckenna grace's little
his little uh she must have had them
both maybe they're twinsies even better
yeah
[Music]
oh and that must be her
yeah i called it yeah young mom got one
reveal okay a young mom he won't wake up
i promise i've given him a heavy
sedative it's probably why you're
feeling sleepy too we just wanted a
private moment with you without gabriel
listening in
he's been telling me to do things bad
things to hurt people gabriel makes me
strong
sometimes he speaks words
he pretends to be nice
but he's the devil
i'm going to wake him up why don't you
come
around after i've injected him
[Music]
but what exactly is gabriel gabriel
is an extreme version of a teratoma a
tumor consisting of tissues hair teeth
muscles bones but more specifically in
this case
it's a parasitic twin
is
underdeveloped twin is dependent on the
body of the other like a parasite
gabriel feeds
off emily it's malignant
[Applause]
an apple
we're starting to suspect that gabriel
can somehow access the region to the
brain that process visual stimuli and
make emily see what he wants her to see
this would explain her recent claims of
hallucinations
why is no one stopping this
not one
other
person willing to jump in no more why
are these no bailiff or anything or
warden
wow
oh
no
oh
it is zoey bell
because they literally share the same
brain i think he's able to trick her
mind make her think she's living her
life as usual essentially placing her
in a mental prison
when in reality
gabriel has hijacked her body and is
using it himself
it's time to cut out the cancer
gabriel's parasitic nature has increased
significantly as he's now siphoning all
fluids and nutrients resulting in severe
weight loss
gabrielle's conjoined at the brain
so full removal wow
wow
course of action would be to remove what
we can and suppress the rest
wow
oh yeah let's do it let's do
it yes
oh my god
is that the stunt woman zoe yeah yeah
zoe bell
yeah
that's why gabriel walks the way he
walks that's why he's all backwards like
oh man
[Applause]
oh
wow
[Music]
gabriel's mad strong
the hell oh she's pushing everybody in
the way now
oh
wow
how did gabriel make the phone call
i'm not sure just brainwave [ __ ] just
telepathically through the electricity i
guess
when derek smashed madison's head
against the wall it woke gabriel up
until that shot wasn't symbolic it was
yeah good call
no need
why the [ __ ] is katie able to do all
this [ __ ] i don't get it
wow
oh dang
oh
oh
sh
show me the making of on that shot
[Music]
oh
man
trick in her mind
nice
[Music]
oh
no
oh
that is mean
is there a detail i missed
this gabriel is so
it's like an alien
i think he's just an evil anomaly of
nature
[Laughter]
with insane martial arts
weapons
mind control insane
unless detective shaw is here with
oh oh
what's wrong oh no
oh that's mean
oh my god oh are you having a heart
attack no
my
pacemaker
okay it's burning
no reuben no
oh
[Music]
please forgive me
i should never have given you away
you were my son
and i should have loved you no matter
what
i know you can hear me you have to fight
him maybe she's not oh madison he killed
your babies he was the cause of your
miscarriages to build himself back up
use it
spider-man 2
go save mary jane
i wanted you to see me
[Music]
oh it's happening around halloween
hey
[Music]
a monster
no gabriel she tricked her mind tricked
his mind
oh cool
nice reversal
now i can do all the mind tricks you
[Music]
you share the same brain
[Laughter]
you don't deserve your body
i can use it better than you
not anymore
it's over gabriel
now you get to live in a world
that i create
you can't lock me in here forever
you'll always be stuck with me
sooner or later i will get out i know
but next time
i'll be ready for you
get this damn thing off of me
i'm so sorry
i'm gonna lift this off you no it's too
heavy it was always my body if he was
strong enough to do this then so am i
[Music]
wow
this is a beautiful story
gets your adrenaline going
blood or not
you will always
be my sister
and i will always
love you
[Music]
i didn't realize that she
what she was learning this whole movie
yeah
yeah that she didn't need to i thought
they were getting along the whole time
no but you know if she hadn't been
craving bloodlust and
revenge on behalf of her
malignant twin
[Music]
does she
get what's incarcerated somewhere now
that's a great question because
technically in the eyes of the law it's
her body
she shouldn't just live a normal life
after this she should at least
re-experiment there are no more cops
to tell the tales so clean slate
no the guy's alive just got hit in the
shoulder
yeah but he's got a crush on her sisters
so he'll go along with anything
now you're you're right i don't know how
she's not going to go to prison right
after this
even if it's not prison but
or some type of institution where they
could keep her under control
she's just going to tell them like no
guys it's a mental game i got it
i talked to gabriel over [ __ ] tim he's
actually i already did the trial
sentenced him he's in prison in my brain
so we're actually not talking with you
about imprisoning gabriel i want you to
come work for us yeah gabriel shows a
very particular set of skills that we
could use in the field
imagine his capabilities with
electronics alone
and his fighting ability
we're talking stopping global terrorism
on a massive scale gabriel
think of all the places gabriel could be
these are eyes and ears and teeth and
flesh inside
well
certainly
has the
aesthetic
and
color palette of it
gelato giallo argento
film
um a gelatin
it is a
very strange indeed
i'd i'd be lying if i said i did not
enjoy it i i quite enjoyed this
it is uh
it is very fun it's very campy and i i
really really like too thinking back on
it
um thinking is how the trailers only
showed you like pretty much stuff from
the first like 30 minutes of this movie
yeah they don't show you
a lot and i thought that and i said it
like a gazillion times i'm like i really
get the idea
well i thought it would be a slower
paced more deliberate film yeah like i i
i was i was picking up on the trailers
being something that is very
different
than i'm like they're clearly trying to
advertise this like a james wong movie
that you've seen before but it's not
going to be that yeah it really got that
sense that there was a mislead that not
a mislead but uh a bad marketing uh when
it came to the trailers for it to make
it just kind of look like a a lower it
felt like a lesser budget more cheesy
version of what he's done before
and then
i mean that's just how i felt about the
trailers maybe you like the trailers uh
as i i enjoyed the trailers because i
could see past what they were actually
presenting
yeah i didn't expect this
yeah i'm not gonna act like i'm not
gonna act like a no at all who expected
this [ __ ] though i didn't i knew not be
what the trailers were yeah but i
thought it would be something way
different
because
usually all the stuff that was happening
in the first half hour would happen much
later in a typical horror movie yeah or
even in a typical james wan horror movie
that stuff would happen later
and then it was just happening fast i'm
like oh damn we're getting all this
trailer [ __ ] out of the way already you
know
like the suspense and build up and then
uh yeah as it kept going you started
getting a better i started getting a
better sense of the tone
with like um it's
the way the dialogue was specifically
being handled
uh where it it did have a bit of that
like
very on the nose
70s
horror kind of vibe where it felt like
it was like it was like a really good
looking b movie like it was like james
mom was just having so much fun with the
camera and the editing
um i love the way he handles perspective
and messing with what you'd expect a
horror scene to go down like i thought
like the first half of this movie
managed to ring out a lot of tension
uh and and scenes where you're like it's
gonna happen it's here no no not
happening here but then
uh the way the reveal started happening
in the last half once he when she goes
to visit her mom and the way how all
that just escalatingly just gets more
and more bizarre
it just got so weird
uh i'd be i'd be lying if i said i
didn't enjoy it because i still
felt i i could feel the purpose of
direction here like it never read to me
like james juan didn't intend for it to
communicate the way it communicates
and so when you can
hear and feel the authenticity of a
director's voice
then
it makes it easier for me to get on
board with
[ __ ] that
and other movies could actually come
across as unintentionally bad or
unintentionally cheesy
it always felt purposeful yeah so that's
why the emotional association to the way
it turned out was like
i'm enjoying this this is since this is
silly this is insane the last half gets
like so
weird
that i'm like i wouldn't really have it
any other way i would like some [ __ ] i'm
not gonna lie though there are things
where uh like i would like some
explanation on some things unless they
just flew over my head or i missed the
line of dialogue that
um you know that just
didn't occur to me because i was like i
just don't get what this gabriel guy is
exactly like i get i love the idea of
how it's like yeah it was born with
um another the real name's emily
madison yeah um how it's born with
madison
and i love that it has this like
sci-fi b movie horror effect
like how they did like practical effects
yeah too
uh it felt like out of you know when you
eat like a romero film to a certain
extent
or something more schlocky than that
yeah
yeah something it almost reminded me
like basket case or something or even
like a cronenberg like when cronenberg's
a much better call yeah yeah cronenberg
is much better yeah yeah that like gross
body horror thing yeah and i mean i feel
like the tone and the camp that is
present here is what helps to bring that
all around because i haven't seen like a
million jealous films and this is you
know updating that style and adding
other i mean yeah kind of everything
from james wan's repertoire uh but there
is something he really felt like he did
a giallo aesthetic but his film yeah
absolutely yeah yeah yeah it's like it
feels like a james bond movie but now
it's bringing in some of those stylistic
earmarks and from those genre of films
that i have seen you know like they are
strange and campy and they do go sort of
insane and shrill by the end and some of
them like i feel like this is more
modern because it doesn't take as much
time to build up you're not slow burning
until some kind of crazy payoff here
there is a crazy payoff but you're more
ramping up and you're feeling the
tension back and forth throughout and i
think that he does a nice job of putting
madison
in her own world that is kind of like
yeah stark and a bit chilling and at
times like you know the most dramatic
stuff in the movie is centered around
and anchored to her and then everybody
else is sort of on the outside looking
in and so i feel like that helps to sell
yeah the more blunt dialogue that comes
from like the cops and stuff like that
because everybody else is on the outside
there's a weird crazy circumstance that
she's involved in yeah and uh yeah like
it as a concept
is so high concept you know it is one of
those things that like you know you
would expect to see in like an old
horror cereal or comic you know it's
like it's a real phenomenon of like oh
yeah people were born with like you know
the the material like they describe it
in the movie but yeah like you know the
genetic materials for a twin or
something but it just isn't formed and
so like you take that nugget of a real
idea you know there's teeth or an eye or
there's you know tissue and then just
expound that out into you know like i
could see the log line easily and i
think what helps this movie along is
that yeah like
it has a master craftsman behind it who
knows how to both
elevate the chills and and give you all
the fun and punchiness that you want but
also actually care to capture the
performances and actually give it a mood
and a tone
beyond all that well so this is sci-fi
horror and i think that was that was the
genre i did not know would be associated
here i thought it would be pure
supernatural terror
then and but the the intro uh the
prologue for it which i thought was a
necessary prologue yeah because if you
don't have that prologue and you just
start off with madison coming home
pregnant domestically by like
it
it is so grounded in the beginning
like it's so grounded with madison's
story in the in the beginning and it
felt like oh we're walking into one of
those horror movies like those
psychological horror films that are
about trauma and yeah which is
still
it is that that's still here but you
know usually those are like a hereditary
or a babadook you know something along
those lines or a good night mommy like
that that that's what i thought we were
getting like it was just like creepy
mother story yeah you know
because that's how the vibe and the and
the s the because it's weird i like how
colorful this movie is
and um
how
how expertly
framed everything is
uh
there
he still has that like washed out gray
aesthetic that he brought with the first
saw movie and even like dead silence
yeah those those procedural stuff like
because he brings back that procedural
quality he loves to mess with yeah and
um which he hasn't done in a while so he
brings that back here
and uh so yeah i thought it was just
going to be a much more patient film
yeah but like in the first 20 minutes
like even if you don't have the prologue
it it just kicks off pretty quick and
the the the prologue though really helps
you to set up the
what this world is
and then when you go into madison that's
what the world slowly becomes like it
starts off real and then it slowly turns
into this uh
into this uh uh this this crazy
ride of a movie that just gets
it so insane to the point where it's not
scary anymore
is it like i thought the first half was
scarier chilling and intense yeah but
then the last half just becomes like
crazy reveals and action scenes and
violence in core but it works for me it
works for me i can't i can't act like it
doesn't work it works
i think that does work a because you
know you got to keep building and if you
are going to do a movie that is clear
like no no we're going to start getting
bonkers right away like i i think it it
brings it around nicely that yeah you
tie it too once she gets cracked in the
head of the beginning that's when the
phenomenon starts really happening and
so that helps to sell the action but i
also feel like because there is so much
that comes out of james one's repertoire
it's important that yeah he go and crest
into a next level of bonkers-ness and
pretty much like right when you get that
chase between gabriel and and kay
uh and you know he's doing all sorts of
martial arts and parkour and jumping up
through the ceiling i'm like yeah we're
in a different level of movie now
well you know it's that it says
it's a spin on the twist of the the
killer is the protagonist yeah it's a
spin on it because the the movies
tells you that right away
it tells you right up front that the
killer is her
you know and every little cl like not
only did they say it in the dialogue
with the detectives but every clue
points to her
but the movie does such a good job at
differentiating them and because of its
rules of what gabriel can do
it has you going for a while like okay
clearly there's some type of real deep
personal connection between the two that
is something else what is it but but the
killer is not her yeah you know like it
has you go in there like okay this
obviously it has to be a mislead that
the killer's not her yeah
and it's technically not her it's just
her body you know yeah but it still
falls close enough into that category
that trope and that twist to be kind of
a clever play on that kind of movie of
the split personality twist that we've
seen done a million times by now in
films that are not even horror but like
just psychological thrillers or
suspenseful films or whatever yeah so
like it's a it's a fresh
it's more than just a split it's not
it's not even really a split personality
because it is a completely different
being a twin taking over her brain
um with
so she like i could totally i totally
see why people would not like this movie
though oh yeah yeah completely again i'm
not i can't go out there and
try to convince anyone this is one of
those movies you're like it either works
for you or really really it's gonna work
for you but uh but i think james won
like he's one of the few directors who
like i don't like every one of his
movies i don't i'm not a fan of
insidious two and uh i'm not a big
aquaman fan to be honest um
like
but for the most part i'm usually a big
fan of his i think the key word is i'm a
big fan of his voice i usually
understand where he's
what he's going for and what he's doing
and so what it's that kind of thing
where sometimes
it's it's the experience of
sometimes it might not it's not more
than james bond sometimes i don't like a
director's movie but then if i like read
interviews or or see what it is they're
going sound like what i have with zack
snyder you know like of like i don't i
didn't really like this but then once i
started understanding deeper what they
were going for then i would watch their
movies then i would go oh i can see and
feel it now and now i really like it
and it's this
same but sometimes with james one that
just sort of clicks for me right away
and this is one of those movies where it
just clicked for me
uh early on because the way it it
weirdly it's not it's more than just the
because there's what i think is great is
that it's there is so much fun
visuals and creepiness and horror going
on from beginning to end it's not like
it's been 10 minutes we need a horror
scene yeah you know like it's kind of
just there for most of it yeah and the
parts where it's shot a little flat are
with the cops yeah you know when in the
beginning like the first half of this
movie where it is just that gray palette
and the but the way the dial what hit me
is the way the dialogue is done and the
transitions with the music cues and the
zoom ins and stuff i'm like oh the real
tone of this movie is actually
established in the dialogue scenes yeah
that helps dictate a lot of how the
experience of this movie went for me
yeah um i think i think when it really
hit me was when
uh madison starts telling her sister on
the bed uh that she's adopted and how
that scene was handled i'm like okay i
get this like that's when i was like i
get what this movie is now yeah yeah
well and i mean there are elements to
that words like even the parts that
become that feel more gray in comparison
to the more uh bombastic and and crazy
lit sequences like it starts to feel
like an aspect of the oppressive world
around and it's always raining and you
know it's like it starts to feel it adds
to the dreariness of the situation that
the protagonist is going through even
though i feel like for this kind of
movie you know we do jump around between
a good amount of different things
there's still kind of like a pace that's
percolating that doesn't seem like it's
too apt to take its time but it's weird
because you spend this whole movie going
what is the twit like what is gonna be
the outcome and in some ways when you
get to the end you're like oh it's all
there and it's all pretty simple once
you get to the end and yet there are
these stylistic elements and these
choices that then start to take on a
greater life just as you're sitting here
kind of picking them all apart and
thinking back as to like this was really
good at making me forget about things
and really just pulling me into scenes
so i wasn't sitting there going but
there's going to be a creature thing
coming back because we saw that in the
prologue you know like i think he's
really good at yet using kind of
everything it's like the the filmmaking
choices are really alive and there are
these beautiful angles to behold that
all seem to or these camera motions that
all seem very well chosen they're not
too in your face flashy but they are
very stylized still they're very and and
yeah like it all goes to serve
just this wacky ride and i think that's
part of the spirit of the movies this is
drawing from is
yeah it is either going to be very much
for you or very much not and that's part
of the fun is that yeah like at the end
of the day the the kernel of the concept
here is a schlocky high concept thing it
really really is but it's it's what's
fun though is that
it knows it's that but it chooses to be
shot incredibly well yeah you know like
it it's modern it's james wannisms
throughout this whole movie
so it he doesn't half-ass the
craftsmanship of the way it's captured
and that's
it it's it's it's unique voice i mean
what other horror movie you're going to
watch these days that it's that's going
to be like this like there's nothing
like it and as much as
i thought like
it just got so red
it it's weird
i'm a little conflicted on the police
breakout scene
uh not not so much when when she's with
the prisoners yeah and she like rips
open the back of her head
uh it's it's more so uh
when she's fighting in the actual big
yeah it's just different and it's just a
straight up action scene yeah like it's
only it's only an action scene at that
point that one take where she's just
decimating fools like it's the church
yeah yeah kingsman yeah that's what i
thought i was just thinking of actually
the king's man rasputin fight scenes
i've seen so far yeah that's kind of
what it looks like yeah yeah um which
also but that's what i mean it feels
like he's been doing it felt like this
was like all of his movies in one yeah
yeah and and even it's funny because you
started out and i'm like you know and
then you look at the first saw and
that's a great example of a movie that
isn't as bloody as you remember it's
feels and and there certainly is some
but like this movie started out and i
was like oh man this is like
gory and mean and bloody and stuff like
that but there's also and and most of
that like practical effects practical
creature work
uh and then really well chosen cgi
because that effect of like the world
melting and fusing into different
settings and things like that i don't
understand the choice to aesthetically
do it that way
ah that's very i know man i get i get
the choice i i get the choice of like
messing with her mind and all that i
just like kind of that like dissolving
watery bubbly effect i didn't i didn't
understa
i know there's a that's the thing is i
know there's a reason that was chosen
and i i can't pinpoint it yeah because
it has a very yeah it has like a it
almost feels like it's bubbling or it's
like tangible but then there are aspects
of it that do feel almost like a digital
simulation like it is
i think because it's so kind of hard to
pin as to like what is this effect aside
from cgi
but uh but even so just like the way
those moments were placed and chosen and
the way that that one i mean like it is
funny because i didn't really i noticed
it in both of those scenes the fight
with the one cop and the fight later i
was like these are just fights these are
just action scenes these are like horror
set pieces these are fights and uh and
yeah like that one take at the end is
like stitched together with some cgi but
it looks really good yeah yeah you know
so it's like there is a silliness almost
about like you're watching a
horror demon guy and there's two sides
on his head and half the time i'm like
oh yeah you're just a stuntman with a
mask on the back of your head but at the
same time something about all that comes
together and sells the sort of
like there's so much happening all the
time and there's so much craftsmanship
all the time that it's hard to not be
swept up in some aspect of it yeah yeah
um
i don't know i don't really know where i
rank it right now
uh i'm not sure either but i definitely
i definitely recommend it only because
if i wouldn't know how to talk about
this movie
properly or feel like i'm doing a
thorough enough job
if it wasn't a spoiler discussion yeah
absolutely like i would honestly hate to
do a non-spoiler talk on this because
i'd just be like it's kind of weird
a lot to take in it's off the walls i'd
be saying all kinds of genres and stuff
but uh i i enjoyed it a lot i i
definitely did and it seems like the
kind of movie that i will like even more
the more i think about it yeah
and definitely distinct and i love that
it is one of those films that it's like
it's so committed to what it is that
you're either gonna
really not like this yeah or you're
going to think it's pretty cool
because yeah because of all the horror
flicks i've seen in a while i feel like
this one is going to i what this just
feels unique i would rather watch this
any day over the conjuring three yeah no
yeah this felt like i was seeing
something clearly it's a specific voice
yeah yeah with a specific voice and that
feels
fresh and not like what i'm used to
seeing in horror movies right now even
if it is borrowing from the past like
this feels like that's the most unique
horror movie i've seen in a minute that
just feels like it's its own movie
yeah it's not too beholden to a million
other movies even though it's borrowing
some style uh the music's cool and i
would also say that uh who's annabelle
wallace yes
where's she from i've seen her and i
couldn't pinpoint it i know she's not
one of them hill house people maybe
other or
like there were two kids from hill house
in this like mckenna grace was also in
annabelle right yeah
or two and three
there's just animals oh she's one the
kid of the warrens right yeah no am i
wrong about that i don't remember it all
over everything i don't know
messed up their mind what kind of grace
is in every
ghost thing right now
the like okay what i really wish is a
better explanation for
anyway elite actress is really great
yeah yeah
yeah she's got an interesting and she
hits it she hits the right barf to play
in a movie like this she hits the right
mark here which it's like it's the right
this is a movie that
where everyone needs to kind of
understand the tone um and the right
pitch to do it where you're not over
doing it where you're
performing the you're like
playing the tone and not being the tone
you got to be hysterical without playing
it yeah cool i think everyone has kind
of that same job of hitting the right
mark on the tone where you're not
overdoing it where we're like
we're intentionally going for cheesy
yeah
but it can't lack
self-awareness
yeah i have to be sincere but self-aware
yeah it's kind of weird how you have to
hit that right that just that right mark
of samurai cop
that's what the true inspiration was for
this
one was like how can i pay tribute
finally that's what we've all been
waiting for uh yeah it's um
i enjoyed it i enjoyed quite a bit and
um after sitting here for two hours
covering something else and then
immediately sitting here it it it was
pretty flew by yeah yeah i can't i can't
act like this wasn't like this is uh
i would want more movies like this to
check out because
it it commits to its concept and it
builds and it has a great pace about it
to this to the idea of how it
it it progressively grows but it it
while it gets like really big and i
never thought it got too big
to the point where you need to cut it
out
[Laughter]
like i i thought it it nat it it got to
where it needed to go to
and
it it builds just right for me like the
first half is the kind of movie you sort
of expect yeah and then the last half is
not what you'd expect and i like that so
uh yeah it builds just right but guys
what did you think about malignant
curious to know what you got to say
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button you can check us on patreon
thanks for being here
[Music]